und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend
Nerven stark und robustes Gemüt die
Eigenschaften wurden heute häufiger
genannt als darum ging Boris Pistorius
zu charakterisieren
Nervenstärke und ein robustes Gemüt wird
er auch dringend brauchen im neuen Amt
als Bundesverteidigungsminister die
Liste der Vorgänger die dieses Amt mit
Schleudertrauma verließen ist lang
Pistorius springt also von der
niedersächsischen Landesebene nicht nur
hoch nach Berlin sondern auch noch
mitten ins Feuer auf den schwierigsten
posten dass er angeblich selbst schon
länger ein Auge auf den Bendlerblock
geworfen hatte und davor keineswegs
zurückschreckt ist wohl eher nützlich
wie gesagt ein robustes Gemüt ist in dem
Job minimal Voraussetzung Thomas
Reichert über die ministerwahl des
Kanzlers und die Reaktionen darauf
Boris Pistorius ist noch gar nicht im
Amt da hat er den Kanzler schon überholt
wir Bundeskanzler hat mich gefragt ob
ich das Amt des
Bundesverteidigungsministers in seinem
Kabinett übernehme
das habe ich dem habe ich sehr dankend
und sehr gerne zugestimmt das mache ich
sehr gerne da ist es in Hannover gerade
13:41 Uhr erst danach um 13:42 Uhr kommt
heute in Brandenburg an der Havel auf
den Punkt ich habe Boris Pistorius
gebeten
Bundesminister der Verteidigung zu
werden er ist nicht nur ein Freund und
ein guter Politiker sondern auch jemand
der über sehr sehr viele Erfahrungen in
der Sicherheitspolitik verfügt aber
vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht so
schwer den Kanzler zu überholen Scholz
hat sehr lange gebraucht die Lamprecht
Nachfolge zu regeln vorgewannen schon
Anfang Januar aber als am Freitagabend
Medien ihren bevorstehenden Rücktritt
melden zeigt sich nichts ist vorbereitet
nichts geklärt wann Scholz ihn angerufen
habe wird Pistorius heute gefragt
gestern er sei sehr überrascht gewesen
im Kabinett sind nun mehr Männer als
Frauen die Grünen finden es gar nicht
lustig das Shorts damit sein
paritätsversprechen bricht für uns Grüne
ist das weiterhin Selbstverständnis und
auch selbstverständlich dass wir die
Hälfte an Frauen mindestens in
Führungsposition haben der
SPD-Fraktionschef schiebt den schwarzen
Peter Fluch der FDP zu die von Anfang an
mehr Männer als Frauen zum Minister
machte ich will Ihnen auch sagen dass
die paritäts überhaupt heute kein
Problem wenn alle Koalitionspartner sich
daran halten würden und das finde ich
sollten eben auch diejenigen mit
beantworten die hoffentlich auch die
Kompetenz von Frauen in dieser Regierung
wertschätzen wir tun das die größte
Oppositionsfraktion ist skeptischer der
neue genug Erfahrung mitbringt für das
Amt
Pistorius kommt nicht aus der
Verteidigungspolitik er wird sich hier
einarbeiten müssen aber
er hat Erfahrung in der Führung eines
Ministeriums wenn auch nur in der
Landespolitik die 100 Tage Einarbeitung
klassisch wird da kaum habe haben aber
er wird auch nicht zaubern können in den
ersten Wochen es gilt jetzt Schwerpunkte
zu setzen historius muss mit entscheiden
ob Deutschland die Lieferung von Leopard
Panzern in die Ukraine erlaubt er muss
seine marode Bundeswehr erneuern die
zumindest kennt der ich war damals
Wehrpflichtiger und sollte Fahrer des
Gepard Panzer werden daraus ist da
nichts geworden weil der Kommandeur
einen neuen Fahrer sucht und dann bin
ich fahre das Kommandeurs geworden vom
Fahrrad zum Minister am Donnerstag wird
Boris Pistorius vereidigt
tja Frage an unserer Hauptstadt
Korrespondentin ich habe gunterla benedy
Pistorius den hatten also zumindest
gestern weniger auf dem Zettel und im
Gespräch waren da eigentlich ja eher
Namen aus der bundesreden ja und es gab
auch schon Spekulationen dass vielleicht
der ein oder andere Name auf Bundesebene
dankend abgelehnt hat bevor Olaf Scholz
Boys Pistorius gefragt hat aber das hat
Rolf Mütze nicht heute zurückgewiesen in
einer Pressekonferenz er selbst war ja
einer der wenigen Eingeweihten die an
der Personalauswahl beteiligt waren und
er sprach von einer Vielzahl von
Personen die gewichtet wurden und
darunter sei Pistorius eben der beste
gewesen er bringt auf jeden Fall viel
Führungserfahrung mit aus einem großen
Ministerium in einem großen Bundesland
und er ist auch nicht der erste der das
Amt des Bundesverteidigungsministers
antritt ohne vorher große
bundespolitische Erfahrungen gemacht zu
haben das hat franz Josef Jung von der
CDU 2005 auch schon gemacht und der war
vier Jahre Ehrenamt aber man muss
natürlich dazu sagen es sind völlig
andere Zeiten heute in Zeiten des
Ukraine Krieges sind die Voraussetzungen
ganz andere und bauspistorius muss
tatsächlich sozusagen von null auf 100
beschleunigen am Donnerstag an dem Tag
an dem er vereidigt wird trifft er schon
seinen us-amtskollegen und am Freitag
einen Tag später ist er auf
internationaler Bühne beim Ukraine
treffen beim Ukraine Unterstützer
treffen und muss sich da auch schon
ordentlich ordentlich schlagen hier in
Berlin macht er jetzt schon das der
Begriff vom Kaltstart die Runde eines
ist Boris Pistorius jedenfalls nicht
eine Frau und damit bricht der Kanzler
ja eigentlich sein wahlversprechendes
halbe halbe Kabinetts aber das Schiene
Berlin heute dann doch mehr relativ
geräuschlos abgeräumt zu werden naja ein
bisschen rumpelt ist schon man hat von
den Grünen heute einige Seiten Liebe
gehört die hier wissen lassen sie sind
jetzt die einzige Partei in der Ampel
die noch die Parität erfüllt tatsächlich
und das können nicht so bleiben auch aus
der SPD gibt es leise Kritik allerdings
muss man sagen dass heute doch eher alle
erleichtert scheinen das nach Tagen der
Ungewissheit jetzt eine Lösung da ist
die auch von der Opposition nur
vorsichtig kritisiert wird und deswegen
kann man wohl sagen dass beim nächsten
Personalwechsel oder bei der nächsten
Personalfrage die Frage wieder auf dem
Tisch ist aber sich heute erst einmal
alle zurückhalten danke schön nach
Berlin
ja wie gesagt am Donnerstag dann
Pistorius seine Ernennungsurkunde vom
Bundespräsidenten erhält trifft er
danach den amerikanischen
Verteidigungsminister und ist dann
gleich mittendrin im kriegsthema in der
Hinsicht gab es auch für Boris Pistorius
eine persönliche Zeitenwende noch 2018
als der damalige SPD Außenminister Heiko
Maas vor zunehmenden russischen
Aggressionen warte gehörte er zu jenen
die den Parteifreund öffentlich
widersprachen und äußerte sogar Zweifel
an den europäischen Sanktionen gegen
Russland seit Kriegsausbruch klingt
Pistorius anders die Ukraine brauche
Unterstützung und müsse gewinnen
welchen Beitrag Deutschland dabei zu
leisten bereit ist wird nun eines seiner
großen Themen sein welche Erfahrungen er
das Amt mitbringt zeichnen Oliver deuker
und Fabian Köhler nach
Abschiedstour im Foyer des
Niedersächsischen Landtages Boris
Pistorius zielstrebig gut gelaunt auf
dem Weg in den Fraktionssaal wo er
hinter verschlossenen Türen mit Standing
Ovations gefeiert wird im Anschluss
warme Worte seines bisherigen Chefs und
Freund
wo ist Pistorius verfügt über die
Fähigkeit
Autorität und Sicherheit zu vermitteln
und das ist etwas was nach innen für die
Bundeswehr vielleicht von sehr großen
Nutzen ist als Innenminister in
Niedersachsen hat er sich eine Namen
gemacht der 62-Jährige Jurist ist
durchsetzungsstark seit 1976
SPD-Mitglied der Sicherheitsexperte gilt
in seiner Partei als konservativ seine
direkte Art wird geschätzt Abitur
kaufmännische Ausbildung Wehrdienst dann
Studium erst Oberbürgermeister in seiner
Heimatstadt Osnabrück dann fast 10 Jahre
Innenminister Pistorius werden schon
seit längerem bundespolitische
Ambitionen nachgesagt als Doppelspitze
bewirkt er sich um den SPD-Vorsitz
scheitert aber jetzt also
Verteidigungsminister sein Plan
ich habe vieles im Kopf das können Sie
mir glauben ich lese seit gestern nichts
anderes mehr und auch in der
Vergangenheit hat mich das Thema stets
interessiert sie wissen dass ich an den
Bundeswehr Fragen immer sehr dich dran
war aber ich werde heute zu dem neuen
Amt dass ich übermorgen erst antrete
inhaltlich noch gar nicht sagen dass
kommt zu gegebener Zeit
Pistorius hat zwei Töchter ist
verwitwett in schwierigen Zeiten
übernimmt er nun den Posten des
Verteidigungsministers der auch schnell
zum schleudersitzt werden kann
und dann wollen wir die militärische
Perspektive auf diesen Posten im
Bundeskabinett hören Egon Rams ist uns
zugeschaltet general ade des Heeres er
war eine der ranghöchsten deutschen
Offiziere bei der NATO unter anderem
Chef des ISAF Einsatzes in Afghanistan
guten Abend
guten Abend Frau Slomka sie haben sich
im Vorfeld auch Gedanken gemacht wer
könnte es werden wann sie heute
überrascht
ich war sehr überrascht weil ich damit
nicht gerechnet hatte ich hatte damit
gerechnet dass irgendwo aus dem Bereich
der Bundespolitik möglicherweise auch
Leute die bereits Erfahrung mit der
Bundeswehr gehabt hätten zur Wahl
gestanden hätten der Kanzler hat sich
für Pistorius entschieden ich gratuliere
Herrn Pistole zu dieser neuen Aufgabe
aber er wird kaltstartfähigkeit brauchen
da gibt es überhaupt keine Frage dass
der eine Punkt dabei und er hat eine
ganze bunte Palette von Aufgaben nicht
nur Blick auf die Ukraine oder
panzerabgaben vor sich liegen an die er
jetzt reingehen muss und dir in die Hand
nehmen muss der kaltstartfähigkeit hat
die Bundeswehr ja auch so ihre Probleme
ist es da nicht ein Mango wenn jemand
kommt der jetzt sagen wir mal nicht aus
der Verteidigungspolitik oder der
Militär Bubble wenn sie auch nennt kommt
also es ist sicherlich ein Grund
möglicherweise an der Entscheidung
Kritik zu üben aber man sollte dem
künftigen Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius kein Misskredit einräumen
sondern sollte ihnen tatsächlich auch
wieder die 100 Tage nicht haben wird die
Chance geben in dieser Aufgabe
reinzuwachsen mir hat auch bei seinen
einführenden Worten hat mir sehr gut
gefallen dass er sich um das Vertrauen
der Soldaten bemühen will denn das ist
etwas wo wir vielleicht in den letzten
sieben acht Jahren partizipierte gehabt
haben lassen Sie uns über diese Defizite
reden wie lief es denn so zwischen
Politik politischer Führung und den
Militärs die am Ende für das operative
zuständig sind wo sahen sie da die
Probleme
also man hat in den letzten Jahren den
Eindruck gehabt dass wenn sich die
Führungsspitze des
Verteidigungsministeriums und das gilt
nicht nur für das letzte Jahr in einigen
Bereichen von der Truppe aber auch von
dem eigenen Ministerium abgekoppelt
hatte es gab da kleine beraterzirkel
kleine Berater Zirkel sind immer
schlecht
Ministerium ist eine ungeheure Kompetenz
und es wird auch jetzt die Kunst für den
neuen Minister Pistorius sein diese
Kompetenz ich sag mal an sich zu ziehen
und sich entsprechend beraten zu lassen
sie gehörten ja auch mal zum
Führungsstab im Bundesministerium der
Verteidigung sie haben eine Zeit lang
für ein Staatssekretärin
Beschaffungswesen gearbeitet also sie
kennen all diese Fallstrecke man sagt
immer wieder das Bundesministerium für
Verteidigung das ist gerade zu
unbeherrschbar da kommt auch ein
Minister oder eine Ministerin im Haus
kaum durch woran liegt das
also es ist sicherlich eines der
komplexesten Ministerien weil die
Aufgaben Vielfalt reicht von dem
Personal der Menschenführung reicht bis
zum Beschaffungswesen mit vielen
Zwischenschritten noch dabei dass der
eine Punkt dabei der zweite Punkt ist
der dass so meine ich
zumindest in den letzten zehn Jahren
aufgrund organisatorische Änderungen die
2011 entschieden worden sind die
zusammenarbeiten im Ministerium nicht
verbessert werden konnten auch dies wird
eine Aufgabe sein mit der sich der neue
Minister intensiv beschäftigen muss und
bald entscheiden muss wo man das
möglicherweise ändern kann da spielen
sie vermutlich darauf an dass der
Planungsstab der sich früher zwischen
Staatssekretäre und Minister schob mit
Experten mit Soldaten mit zivilen
Kräften besetzt dass der von Mutter von
der Thomas der mir sehr abgesetzt wurde
nicht nur Frau somka ich war mal Chef
des Stabes des Führungsstabes der
Streitkräfte einen solchen Führungsstab
und das war der wuchtigste Stab im
Ministerium gibt es nicht mehr sondern
das ist alles aufgekammert worden und
aufgefächert worden auf verschiedene
Abteilungen zum Beispiel die Bundeswehr
Planung wurde früher auch in diesem
Führungsstab bestreitkräfte gemacht
heute haben wir eine eigene
Planungsabteilung und wenn man zwischen
dieser Aufgabe immer Abteilungsgrenzen
dazwischen ist das möglicherweise nicht
hilfreich dann ist die Reform des
Ministeriums oder auch der Bundeswehr
die eine Herkulesaufgabe auf der anderen
Seite haben wir einen großkrieg in
Europa am Freitag wir haben schon gehört
Rammstein dann werden sich die
Unterstützer Nationen die
Verteidigungsminister wieder treffen
erwarten Sie das spätestens dann
Deutschland Farbe bekennen muss und
Leoparden eines oder zwei also
Kampfpanzer liefert
also Farbe bekennen wird Deutschland am
Freitag in jedem Fall müssen so oder so
ob der Po oder Konter rauskommt im
Ergebnis
sie müssen Farbe bekennen zu welcher
Richtung sieht tendieren und ich möchte
darauf verweisen dass der Druck mit
Blick auf das Verhalten Großbritanniens
mit Blick auf das Verhalten Polens die
Blick auf das Verhalten der finden und
noch einiger europäischer Länder in den
letzten
48/72 Stunden ständig größer geworden
ist von daher wäre es tatsächlich gut
dort eine Entscheidung zu treffen die
dann auch der Ukraine hilft denn es gibt
ja letztendlich auch um die Soldaten und
die Menschen in der Ukraine und deren
Leben generell Egon Rams danke für das
Gespräch
danke gerne
ja nach möglichen leopardenlieferungen
wurde heute auch der Bundeskanzler schon
gefragt im Vorfeld seines Auftritts beim
Weltwirtschaftsforum in Davos der heißt
der Kanzler morgen hin gegenüber dem
britischen Kollegen von Bloomberg News
äußerte er sich Scholz like eher
kryptischmann Stimme sich mit
verbündeten ab aber das sei nicht
geeignet für öffentliche Diskussionen
der russische Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine und seine Folgen sind natürlich
auch in Davos das beherrschende Thema zu
den Gastrednern die dort heute auftraten
gehörte unter anderem die First Lady der
Ukraine Olena selenska
und Julia Reich Berichten aus Davos
einmal im Jahr treffen sich die
Mächtigen in beschaulicher Landschaft in
einem Bergdorf und wollen Botschaften in
die Welt aussenden da wusste liegt rund
800 Kilometer entfernt von der
Hauptstadt Berlin eine Botschaft
schickten sie heute direkt dorthin an
Bundeskanzler Scholz bereits am Morgen
ging es um die Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern in die Ukraine der polnisch
und der litauische Präsident sind dafür
der deutsche Bundeskanzler sperrt sich
bis jetzt dagegen
jemand muss die politische Führung
übernehmen damit die Ukraine unterstützt
wird denn die Kampfpanzer spielen eine
entscheidende strategische Rolle glauben
sie Bundeskanzler Scholz übernimmt diese
Führung ich gehe fest davon aus dass er
eine Entscheidung trifft
die beiden Osteuropäer machen sich fast
einen Spaß daraus den Kanzler unter
Druck zu setzen
die die Panzer ja herstellen mitmachen
und sie liefern
[Applaus]
auch das erhofft sie sich von den
deutschen Olena selenska die Frau des
ukrainischen Präsidenten ist der
Stargast des Forums mit einer klaren
Botschaft
jeder hat das Recht auf ein Leben in
Freiheit und Frieden deshalb gibt es nur
eine Lösung die russischen Truppen
müssen sich komplett aus der Ukraine
zurückziehen das Weltwirtschaftsforum
will selenska eine große Bühne bieten
und sie nutzt sie fuhr nach ihrer Rede
in das ukraine-haus an der Promenade die
kriegssehnen die sie dort ausstellen
bedrückend der Besuch und die Bilder
sollen ihren Worten Nachdruck verleihen
auch ein anderer kam aus dem Krieg nach
Davos Vitali Klitschko der Bürgermeister
von Kiew und auch er hat eine Botschaft
dabei
unsere Soldaten zahlen die größte Preis
Preis seines Lebens für
unsere Universität wir kämpfen und
deswegen wie ich wir rechnen am Meer
Unterstützung von schwere Waffen
brauchen wir auch gut auf Finnland
unterstützt die Lieferung schwerer
Panzer die Regierungschefin sanamarin
spricht über die Angst ihres Volkes vor
dem großen Nachbarn Russland
wenn der Ukraine ein Mitglieder der NATO
gewesen wäre dann hätten wir jetzt
keinen Krieg deshalb wollen wir Mitglied
der NATO werden wir wollen nie mehr
Krieg in Finnland erleben einen Krieg
mit Russland hatten wir schon
morgen wird Olaf Scholz seine Rede in
Davos halten alle werden darauf warten
ob es sich in der panzerfrage bewegt und
am Abend laufen im Ukraine Haus zwei
Kinder durch das befreite Herzen
zum Treffen in Davos und den aktuellen
Fragen der Weltpolitik gibt es nachher
im heute journal Update noch ein
Gespräch mit Christoph Heusgen dem
Leiter der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
und die Nachrichten beginnen jetzt mit
der aktuellen Lage der Ukraine die Zahl
der Menschen die durch den russischen
Raketenangriff vom vergangenen Samstag
in der Stadt nepro getötet worden ist
noch ukrainischen Angaben auf 45
gestiegen und es war laut der Regierung
in Kiew auch mit Blick auf die
Energieversorgung einer der
verheerendsten Angriffe seit
Kriegsbeginn mehrere Blöcke von
Wärmekraftwerken und Umspannwerke in
verschiedenen Regionen des Landes sein
getroffen worden
in nepro hatten Rettungskräfte seit
Samstag in den Trümmern nach
Überlebenden des Einschlags gesucht
unter den 45 Todesopfern sein auch sechs
Kinder 79 Menschen wurden verletzt etwa
400 Menschen verloren ihre Wohnung
der Weg nach Deutschland soll für
Fachkräfte aus dem Ausland attraktiver
werden das haben Bundeskanzler Scholz
und Außenministerin baerbock bei einem
Besuch im Bundesamt für auswärtige
Angelegenheiten betont die
Bundesregierung wolle das Visumverfahren
für ausländische Fachkräfte künftig
deutlich verbessern und das
Aufenthaltsgesetz modernisieren so der
Kanzler damit soll Deutschland auch für
Fachkräfte außerhalb Europas ein
attraktiveres Einwanderungsland werden
der Solidaritätszuschlag der inzwischen
nur noch von Gutverdienern gezahlt
werden muss ist auf dem Prüfstand in
einem Verfahren am Bundesfinanzhof heute
war mündliche Verhandlung es geht auch
um die Frage ob der Soli in seiner
jetzigen Form noch verfassungsgemäß ist
oder etwa gegen den
Gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz verstößt das
Gericht kündigte seine Entscheidung für
Ende des Monats an
einer der Hauptverdächtigen im
korruptionskandal um das EU-Parlament
per Antonio panzeri will nach Justiz
Angaben Aussagen und mit den Ermittlern
zusammenarbeiten panzeri habe eine
Erklärung unterzeichnet über finanzielle
Absprachen mit Drittstaaten beteiligte
Personen und weitere Aspekte auszusagen
teilte die belgische Staatsanwaltschaft
mit im Gegenzug werde seine Strafe
gemildert panzeri und auch die ehemalige
Vizepräsidentin evakaieli und ihr
Lebensgefährte sind wegen der
Korruptionsaffäre in Untersuchungshaft
in Belarus hat ein Prozess gegen die ins
Exil geflohene
Oppositionsführerin Svetlana
tichanowskaja begonnen die 2020 bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl macht aber
Lukaschenko herausgefordert hatte hier
wird in Abwesenheit mit vier weiteren
Angeklagten Hochverrat Verschwörung mit
dem Ziel der verfassungswidrigen macht
Ergreifung sowie die Bildung einer
extremistischen Gruppierung vorgebauten
selbst bezeichnete das Verfahren als
Fachs
sie kamen am frühen Morgen des 25
November 2019 um einen Film Reifen Q
hinzulegen einen meisterdiebstahl sowie
George Clooney und Brad Pitt in Ocean's
Eleven so erzählen Sie es selbst einen
Abenteuer sei das gewesen eine Mutprobe
um sich in den eigenen Kreisen einen
Namen zu machen wobei das Grüne Gewölbe
in Dresden nicht die erste Raubzug war
zumindest einer der Täter war im Jahr
davor schon am Goldmünzen Diebstahl in
Berliner bodenmuseum beteiligt dass
diese Einbrüche überhaupt möglich waren
ist genauso unfassbar wie die
Geschichten die die Täter jetzt vor
Gericht erzählen etwa das eine
Klassenfahrt nach Dresden die
Inspiration für den Juwelen Raub
lieferte
Stefan Kirch Bericht
drei Geschichten werden heute erzählt
eine handelt von dem Jungen mit der
Drogensucht und der Wahnvorstellung ein
gefeierter Meisterdieb zu sein in einer
wilder Held durch seine schier
unglaubliche Tat auch mal wahrgenommen
werden im klaren und einer erzählt von
sich als dem Typen der am Ende gar
nichts von dem jahrhundert Kuh hatte
außerdem heutigen Satz ich war der mit
der Taschenlampe
[Musik]
egal was ihr erzählen das überhaupt vor
Gericht aussagen das überrascht
Polizisten wie Benjamin jedenro der sich
mit kleinen Kriminalität auskennt also
im Regelfall ist es so dass arabische
Großfamilie die Straftaten begangen
haben nicht unbedingt mit
Sicherheitsbehörden zusammenarbeiten das
heißt weder mit Polizei noch mit einer
Staatsanwaltschaft da ist man relativ
still der Fall redet man auch nicht
unbedingt mit Peter weil man unsere
Rechtsstaatlichkeit auch einfach ablehnt
und dementsprechend auch alle
Institution noch hatte dieser
Rechtsstaat wohl Zähne gezeigt die
Staatsanwaltschaft deutlich gemacht dass
die Beweislage gegen die Diebe für viele
Jahre Gefängnis reichen würde es sei
denn Verteidigung und Gericht lassen
sich folgenden Deal ein Geständnis und
Beute gegen einen deutlichen Strafen
Nachlass die Alternative wäre gewesen
dass das Gericht sich diesem
Verständigung versucht der eines das
Gerichte angetragen wurde ist von
vornherein verschlossen hätte das hätte
voraussichtlich zur Folge gehabt dass
dieser Schmuck nie wieder auf
aufgetaucht wäre und ich glaube dann
wäre der Aufschrei deutlich größer
gewesen
kein Aufschrei dennoch unüberhörbar eine
Frage was wiegt mehr der Wunsch nach
harter Bestrafung der Liebe oder der
Wunsch die gestohlenen Juwelen
zurückzubekommen
Strafverfahren soll es um Wahrheit und
Gerechtigkeit geben
Wahrheit und Gerechtigkeit sind aber
keine Probleme die per Verständigung
erzielt werden sondern Wahrheit und
Gerechtigkeit müssen durch Tatsachen
Erforschung und den Versuch ein
gerechtes Urteil zu finden erzeugt
werden das sind die Probleme und das
bleiben sie auch die Probleme dieses
Prozesses denn der Deal stellt den
geständigen frei etwas zu sagen zu
hinter Männern oder zum Verbleib der
restbeute
darunter eine der weltweit berühmtesten
brillianten der sogenannte sächsische
Weise 50 Karat schwer zu ihm gab es
heute keine Geschichte
[Musik]
und mit legalen Formen des Gelderwerbs
geht es jetzt bei eins weiter die Zahl
der Aktionäre in Deutschland hat im
vergangenen Jahr einen Rekordstand
erreicht so Zahlen des deutschen
aktieninstituts denen zufolge lässt sich
auch sagen Frank Bethmann in welcher
Altersgruppe ist den größten Anstieg gab
ja bei den unter 30-Jährigen über
600.000 jüngere Menschen investierten im
vergangenen Jahr erstmalig in Aktien
oder Aktienfonds und das in einem
Krisenjahr in dem es ja auch bei den
Aktien deutlich nach unten ging
überraschend ein Grund für diese
Entwicklung Neo Broker online Depot
Anbieter dort könne man via Smart Phone
App auch kleine Beträge einfach anlegen
hört man häufig aus dieser Altersgruppe
die aber auch grundsätzlich weniger
Berührungsängste mit Aktien zu haben
scheint wie aus einer aktuellen Umfrage
des Bankenverbandes hervorgeht Aktien
als Altersabsicherung können sich
demnach sieben von zehn vorstellen nicht
zuletzt erfreuen sich Aktien Spar Szene
also Sparpläne bei denen man regelmäßig
Anteile an Aktienfonds erwirbt größer
werdender Beliebtheit das alles zusammen
hat dazu geführt dass 2022 so viele
Menschen in Deutschland ihr Geld in
diese Kapitalanlage steckten wie nie
zuvor fast 13 Millionen 4,5 Millionen
mehr als noch 20 10 im Jahr nach der
Finanzkrise trotz dieser Zahlen ein Land
der Aktionäre ist Deutschland deswegen
noch lange nicht in anderen
Industriestaaten ist die aktionärsquote
also die Quote die angibt wie viele
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Aktien besitzen
teils deutlich höher Frank Bethmann
vielen Dank
bei einem Brand in einer
Pflegeeinrichtung in Reutlingen sind am
Abend nach ersten Meldungen drei
Menschen ums Leben gekommen zwei weitere
wurden schwer verletzt und mehrere
erlitten leichte Verletzungen der Brand
soll inzwischen gelöscht sein die
Brandursache ist noch nicht bekannt
China meldet zum ersten Mal seit sechs
Jahrzehnten einen Bevölkerungsrückgang
Ende Dezember habe das Land
1,411 Milliarden Einwohner gehabt und
damit rund 850.000 weniger als ein Jahr
zuvor gab das Statistikamt in Peking
bekannt nach dem Ende der ein Kind
Politik dürfen Paare inzwischen drei
Kinder bekommen ein geboten Boom ist
trotzdem geblieben
Tennis Olympiasieger Alexander Zverev
hat rund 7 Monate nach seiner
Fußverletzung einen erfolgreichen Start
bei den Australian Open geschafft er
gewann sein Auftaktspiel gegen den
Peruaner Juan Pablo varias und steht
damit in der zweiten Runde in Melbourne
bei der Handball WM gegen die schon
sicher für die Hauptrunde qualifizierte
deutsche Mannschaft heute in ihr letztes
Gruppenspiel gegen Algerien und gewann
klar mit 37 zu 21
die Party mit den deutschen Handballern
geht weiter nach nur kurzer Anlaufphase
dreht das dab-team gegen Algerien in
schon bekannter Mania auf zuspielt nur
auf Kohlbacher die erste Führung für
Deutschland die Vorteile nie mehr ihnen
gefragt die Paraden des wiedergegebenen
Torhüters Wolf tun ihr übriges als
Spielmacher Knorr diesen sieben Meter
verwandelt ist die Partie mit 16 zu 9
zur Pause fast entschieden Keeper
Wolfgang fortan seinen Stellvertreter
feiern auch Bier im stark zwischen den
Pfosten gegen allerdings extrem schwache
Algerien der zweite Anzug sitzt im
Bengel etwa mit vier Treffern bei seiner
WM Premiere den besten deutschen bleibt
das letzte Tor vorbehalten Kreisläufer
Kohlbacher 10 Treffer im zehnten
versucht Deutschland gewinnt mit 37 zu
21 und tanzt weiter in der Hauptrunde am
Donnerstag gegen Argentinien
das war es ihm heute schon mal gleich
nach dem Wetter geht es mit der
Reportage Reihe 37 Grad weiter und um
00:15
Uhr wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend das ist ein richtiges
Tiefdruck Ballett was sie gleich zu
sehen bekommen auf unserem Wolken Schnee
und Regen vorschaufeln der Schnee ist
hier rosa eingefärbt und der Regen blau
und sie sehen wie es heute Nacht noch
etwas Schnee hier ganz im Norden gibt
dann aber vor allen Dingen die
Schneefälle in Süddeutschland und bis
morgen Abend kommt ein neues Tief hier
an der Nordsee an heute Nacht also gibt
es Schneeschauer an der Nordsee und
zwischen der Ostsee und der Mosel ist
der Himmel zum Teil auch klar Richtung
Süden und südostenfeld dagegen Schnee da
können durchaus einige Zentimeter
zusammenkommen machen sie sich auf
rutschige Straßen gefasst denn die
Temperaturen sinken doch eigentlich
überall in den Frost und besonders eisig
wird sie im Sauerland und dem
Rothaargebirge über Schnee sinken da die
Werte bis minus 9 Grad die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen -1 und plus 4 Grad und die
Wetter drei Teilung der Nacht bleibt uns
auch über Tag erhalten in
Schleswig-Holstein gibt's morgen einige
Schnee Regenschauer und zwischen Rügen
und der Eifel sind sie auch häufiger mal
die Sonne Richtung Bühnen und Südosten
dagegen fällt immer noch etwas Schnee
und jetzt schauen wir uns die Wetterlage
für den Donnerstag noch mal an denn das
wird spannend wir haben hier immer noch
dieses Tief über Südosteuropa und das
Tief über der Nordsee und das ist ganz
entscheidend von welcher Seite der
Schnee zu uns kommt wir gehen davon aus
dass es am Donnerstag in der Westhälfte
Schnee und Schneeregen gibt und ab
Freitag dann von Osten guten Abend